>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
AND WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
ANOTHER CHAPTER IN THE HOUSE
IMPEACHMENT MELLA DRAMA
UNFOLDED TODAY.
ABOUT THE 18TH MOST
IMPORTANT THING HAPPENING IN
AMERICA BUT WE ARE IN
WASHINGTON.
IT HAPPENED.
SO WE ARE GOING TO FRAME IT
FOR YOU THIS EVENING.
SO, THE DRAMA SHIFTED FROM
ADAM SCHIFF'S JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE -- I MEAN RATHER
INTEL COMMITTEE TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WHICH IS
RUN BY ANOTHER DEMOCRATIC
MEMBER OF CONGRESS JERRY
NADLER OF NEW YORK.
LAST MONTH YOU WILL REMEMBER
ADAM SCHIFF'S APPROACH WAS
TO BRING DOWN THE PRESIDENT
BY BRINGING IN A WHOLE
CAVALCADE OF INTEL AND
FOREIGN POLICY PROFESSIONALS
AND HAVING THEM EXPLAIN HOW
THEIR FEELINGS HAD BEEN HURT
BY THE BAD ORANGE MAN.
THE PRESIDENT SAID NASTY
THINGS ABOUT ME.
HE FIRED ME.
I WANTED TO CRY.
MAKE HIM GO AWAY.
IT DIDN'T WORK.
SO JERRY NADLER TRIED A NEW
APPROACH TODAY.
HIS STRATEGY WAS TO TREAT
IMPEACHMENT LIKE A FACULTY
MEETING AT WESLEYAN.
SO PRODUCE A LONG LINE OF
ACADEMICS WITH IMPRESSIVE
SOUNDING CREDENTIALS, HAVE
THEM CONDEMN THE PRESIDENT
AS A VERY BAD MAN.
AND IF YOU WEREN'T PAYING
CLOSE ATTENTION, YOU WERE
STANDING IN LINE AT THE
CAFETERIA AND JUST SAW IT
OUT OF THE CORNER OF YOUR
EYE, YOU MIGHT HAVE BEEN
IMPRESSED.
THAT WAS THE IDEA.
WATCH.
>> THE EVIDENCE REVEALS THE
PRESIDENT WHO USED THE
POWERS OF HIS OFFICE TO
DEMAND THAT A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT PARTICIPATE IN
UNDERMINE AGO COMPETING
CANDIDATE FOR THE
PRESIDENCY.
IF WE ARE TO KEEP FAITH WITH
OUR CONSTITUTION AND WITH
OUR REPUBLIC, PRESIDENT
TRUMP MUST BE HELD TO
ACCOUNT.
>> IF CONGRESS FAILS TO
IMPEACH HERE, THEN THE
IMPEACHMENT PROCESS HAS LOST
ALL MEANING.
>> I STAND WITH THE
CONSTITUTION AND I STAND
WITH THE FRAMERS WHO WERE
COMMITTED TO ENSURE THAT NO
ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
>> ON THE BASIS OF THE
TESTIMONY AND THE EVIDENCE
BEFORE THE HOUSE, PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS COMMITTED
IMPEACHABLE HIGH CRIMES AND
MISDEMEANORS BY CORRUPTLY
ABUSING THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENCY.
>> Tucker: OH, YEAH.
THAT SOUNDS BAD.
AND AS YOU JUST HEARD THE
FRAMERS WOULD FROWN UPON IT.
WHAT WOULD THEY THINK
SPECIFICALLY?
WELL FORTUNATELY JERRY
NADLER ASKED THAT QUESTION
AND WITNESS NOAH FELDMAN HAD
AN ANSWER.
HERE IT WAS.
>> IF WASHINGTON WERE HERE
TODAY, IF HE WERE JOINED BY
MADISON, HAMILTON AND OTHER
FRAMERS, WHAT DO YOU BELIEVE
THEY WOULD SAY IF PRESENTED
WITH THE EVIDENCE BEFORE US
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
CONDUCT?
>> I BELIEVE THE FRAMERS
WOULD IDENTIFY PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S CONDUCT AS EXACTLY
THE KIND OF ABUSE OF OFFICE
HIGH CRIME AND MISDEMEANOR
THAT THEY WERE WORRIED
ABOUT.
>> Tucker: UM-HUH.
MADISON, HAMILTON,
WASHINGTON.
THESE ARE BASICALLY THE SAME
PEOPLE THE LEFT WOULD LIKE
TO SEE DETHRONED.
THEIR STATUES KNOCKED OVER
BY SCREAMING COLLEGE KIDS.
THEY MUST BE VERY BAD MEN.
SO PRESUMABLY, IF EVEN THEY
THINK TRUMP IS ROTTEN, THEN
IMPEACHMENT MANDATORY.
OF COURSE, ONCE YOU PAUSE
AND CONSIDER THIS ALL FOR A
MOMENT IT, STARTS TO LOOK A
LITTLE LESS IMPRESSIVE.
NONE OF TODAY'S WITNESSES
HAD ANY ACTUAL EVIDENCE
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
THEY WERE INSTEAD GIVING YOU
THEIR OPINIONS.
IT WAS A LITTLE BIT LIKE
READING THE NEW REPUBLIC BUT
LESS INTERESTING.
YOU PROBABLY HEARD ENOUGH
IMPEACHMENT OPINIONS OVER
THANKSGIVING ONE FROM OF
YOUR DRUNK COUSINS.
SO WHY WOULD WE CARE WHAT
THESE PEOPLE THINK?
HMMM, WELL, BECAUSE OF THEIR
CREDENTIALS.
SUPPOSEDLY THEY HAVE
EXCEPTIONAL KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERTISE.
IQs FAR HIGHER THAN YOURS.
ALL OF WHICH ENABLES THEM TO
GIVE A FAIR AND BALANCED AND
A FORMED OPINION ON HOW
AMERICA OUGHT TO PROCEED.
BUT IS THAT REAL?
WELL, CONSIDER TODAY'S STAR
WITNESS, PAM KARLAN.
LOOK UP HER BIOGRAPHY ONLINE
SHE IS THE KENNETH AND
HARVARD MONTGOMERY INTEREST
LAW AT STANFORD.
STAND BACK, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
AND BEFORE THAT SHE CLERKED
FOR A SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
AND EARNED NOT ONE, NOT TWO,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, SHE
EARNED THREE SEPARATE
DEGREES AT YALE.
SHE HAS WRITTEN SEVERAL
TEXTBOOKS ON CONSTITUTIONAL
LAW.
IF THERE IS ONE PERSON IN
THIS COUNTRY WHO IS
IMPRESSIVE, WHO OUR SYSTEM
HAS DEEMED CAPABLE OF MAKING
JUDGMENTS THAT YOU DON'T
EVEN UNDERSTAND, IT'S THIS
LADY.
THIS PROFESSOR, PAMELA
KARLAN.
BUT THINK AGAIN.
AND THIS IS A SUBTHEME OF
THE IMPEACHMENT DRAMA THAT
WE WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
BECAUSE REALLY IT'S THE
THING THAT WILL ENDURE AND
CHANGE THE COUNTRY LONG
AFTER TRUMP IS GONE.
IT TURNS OUT THE MORE YOU
KNOW ABOUT THE PEOPLE YOU
ARE SUPPOSED TO CONSIDER
IMPRESSIVE, THE MORE YOU
FIND OUT THEY ARE NOT
IMPRESSIVE AT ALL.
ACTUALLY.
THEY ARE NOT VERY SMART.
THEY HAVE NO WISDOM.
THEIR PERSONAL LIVES ARE A
DISASTER.
BY THE WAY, IF THEY ARE SO
WISE, WHY ARE THEY SO
UNHAPPY?
EVERY ONE OF THEM IS.
AND IN THIS SPECIFIC CASE
THEY ARE NOT EVEN UNBIASED
ARBITERS.
KARLAN, FOR EXAMPLE, SHE IS
NOT SOME A POLITICAL
ACADEMIC PULLED OUT OF COLD
STARGE TO TESTIFY WHAT WE
ARE TO DO.
SHE IS LIVING ROOMILY A
POLITICAL ACTIVIST WHO DON'T
UNITED STATES THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
WATCH THIS.
>> PROFESSOR KARLAN, YOU
GAVE 2,000 BUCKS OR YOU GAVE
1,000 BUCKS TO ELIZABETH
WARREN, RIGHT?
>> I BELIEVE SO.
>> YOU GAVE 1200 BUCKS TO
BARACK OBAMA?
>> I HAVE NO REASON TO
QUESTION THAT.
>> AND YOU GAVE 2,000 BUCKS
TO HILLARY CLINTON?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
>> Tucker: SO DOES DONATING
TO DEMOCRATS PROVE THAT
KARLAN IS WRONG, NO.
IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY.
SHE PROVED THAT HERSELF.
SHE MADE IT VERY CLEAR THAT
SHE WAS INCAPABLE OF CLEAR
THINKING OR WISE JUDGMENTS.
INSTEAD SHE MADE BIZARRE
CLAIMS.
SHE CLAIMED THAT DELAYING
MILITARY AID TO UKRAINE WAS
LIKE CUTTING OFF RESCUE
SERVICES TO AMERICANS AFTER
A HURRICANE.
WHAT?
INSANE AND DUMB BY THE WAY.
SHE ALSO ENGAGED IN
EMBARRASSING POLITICAL
STUNTS LIKE RIDICULING A
PRESIDENT'S TEENAGER SON.
WHAT?
>> WHAT COMPARISONS
PROFESSOR KARLAN CAN WE MAKE
BETWEEN KINGS THAT THE
FRAMERS WERE AFRAID OF AND
THE PRESIDENT'S CONDUCT
TODAY?
>> THE CONSTITUTION SAYS
THERE CAN BE NO TITLES OF
NOBILITY.
SO WHILE THE PRESIDENT CAN
NAME HIS SON BARRON, HE
CAN'T MAKE HIM A BARRON.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THANK YOU, THE
FOUNDING --
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: YEAH.
WONDER HOW LONG THEY
PRACTICED THAT ONE IN THE
MIRROR?
IT WAS PETTY AND DUMB.
NOT SURPRISING THOUGH.
KARLAN HAS MADE REMARKS LIKE
THIS BEFORE.
SHE PREVIOUSLY SUGGESTED
THAT JEFF SESSIONS WAS EVIL.
WHY?
BECAUSE OF THE NAME HIS
PARENTS GAVE HIM.
WHAT A MEDIOCRITY.
IN 2006 WELL BEFORE THE REST
OF THE LEFT EMBRACED THE
GREAT AWOKENNING.
KARLAN WAS AHEAD THE GAME.
SHE WAS ALREADY BASHING
PEOPLE ON THE BASIS OF SEX,
SKIN COLOR AND SEXUAL
ORIENTATION.
WATCH.
THIS WE HAVE TO SEIZE BACK
THE HIGH GROUND ON
PATRIOTISM AND LOVE OF OUR
COUNTRY BECAUSE WE HAVE MORE
REASON AN THEY DO TO LOVE
AMERICA.
THE RICH, PAMPERED PRODIGAL
SANCTIMONIOUS INCURIOUS
WHITE, STRAIGHT SONS OF THE
POWERFUL DO PRETTY WELL
EVERYWHERE IN THE WORLD AND
THEY ALWAYS HAVE.
>> Tucker: THIS LADY NEEDS A
SHRINK.
THE SONS OF THE POWERFUL?
REALLY?
YOU ARE A LAW PROFESSOR AT
STANFORD AND YOU ARE
LECTURING OTHER PEOPLE HOW
THEY ARE POWERFUL?
RIGHT.
THIS IS THE LEGENDARY
SCHOLAR COMING DOWN FROM ON
HIGH TO TELL US WHO IS GOOD
AND WHO IS EVIL.
PLEASE, WHAT A MEDIOCRITY
WHAT A MORON.
HER FELLOW WITNESSES WERE
ALMOST AS EMBARRASSING.
NEIL FELDMAN PROFESSOR AT
HARVARD LAW SCHOOL TOLD
LAWMAKERS THAT HE WAS
SKEPTICAL OF IMPEACHMENT
UNTIL THIS PAST SUMMER
SUGGESTING, OF COURSE, THAT
HIS ENDORSEMENT IS MORE
LEGITIMATE.
NOT POLITICAL.
TURNS OUT THAT WAS A LIE.
IT WAS A LIE.
HOW DO WE KNOW?
BECAUSE ALL THE WAY BACK IN
MARCH OF 2017, THE SAME MAN,
NOAH FELDMAN SUGGESTED THAT
TRUMP SHOULD BE IMPEACHED
BECAUSE OF A TWEET HE SENT
ACCUSING PRESIDENT OBAMA OF
MONITORING TRUMP TOWER.
THAT WAS IMPEACHABLE.
HE SAID.
HE ALSO SAID THAT JIM
COMEY'S MEMO OF HIS
CONVERSATIONS WITH TRUMP WAS
IMPEACHMENT-WORTHY, TOO.
HE EVEN TOLD SLATE.COM,
PLEASE, SO IMPRESSIVE WHY IS
HE WRITING FOR SLATE,
WHATEVER.
BUT HE TOLD SLATE THAT THE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T ACTUALLY
HAVE THE FREE SPEECH AND
SHOULD BE IMPEACHED SIMPLY
FOR SAYING THINGS THAT NOAH
FELDMAN DOESN'T LIKE.
THE ONLY WITNESS WHO DIDN'T
ELM PRAYER WAS HIMSELF TODAY
WAS GEORGETOWN PROFESSOR
JONATHAN TURLEY.
DESCRIBING TURLEY AS A
G.O.P. WITNESS DESCRIBING
WHITE WINGER OR A REPUBLICAN
EVEN.
IS HE NONE OF THOSE THINGS.
TURLEY HAS HO HAS COME ON
THE SHOW QUITE A BIT.
KNOW HIM WELL IS A MEMBER OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HE IS ON THE LEFT.
HE HAS ADVOCATED LEGALIZING
POLYGAMY.
HE WANTED GEORGE W. BUSH
TRIED FOR WAR CRIMES.
IS HE NOT FROM THE
FEDERALIST SOCIETY.
HE DOESN'T LIKE TRUMP.
HE DIDN'T VOTE FOR HIM.
BUT HE CALLED AN ABSURDITY
WHERE HE SAW ONE.
>> I'M NOT A SUPPORTER OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I VOTED AGAINST HIM.
MY PERSONAL VIEWS OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP ARE AS
IRRELEVANT TO MY IMPEACHMENT
TESTIMONY AS THEY SHOULD BE
TO YOUR IMPEACHMENT VOTE.
I GET IT.
YOU'RE MAD.
THE PRESIDENT'S MAD.
MY REPUBLICAN FRIENDS ARE
MAD.
MY DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS ARE
WILL A SLIPSHOD IMPEACHMENT
MAKE US LESS MAD?
WILL IT ONLY INVITE AN
INVITATION FOR THE MADNESS
TO FOLLOW EVERY FUTURE
ADMINISTRATION?
THAT IS WHY THIS IS WRONG.
IT'S NOT WRONG BECAUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS RIGHT.
HIS CALL WAS ANYTHING BUT
PERFECT.
IT'S NOT WRONG BECAUSE THE
HOUSE HAS NO LEGITIMATE
REASON TO INVESTIGATE THE
UKRAINIAN CONTROVERSY.
IT'S NOT WRONG BECAUSE WE'RE
IN AN ELECTION YEAR.
THERE IS NO GOOD TIME FOR AN
IMPEACHMENT.
NO.
IT'S WRONG BECAUSE THIS IS
NOT HOW YOU IMPEACH AN
AMERICAN PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
THAT'S ALL IT IS.
EVERYONE IN WASHINGTON IS
MAD ABOUT SOMETHING.
MENTALLY FRAGILE AGE LIKE
THIS ONE.
EVERYONE REQUIRES A NUCLEAR
RESPONSE.
DONALD TRUMP THINKS HAITI
ISN'T A NICE COUNTRY.
HE IS A RACIST.
HE WANTS TO HAVE A BORDER
AROUND OUR COUNTRY?
BIGOT.
HE THINKS IT'S SUSPICIOUS
WHEN THE CORRUPT DO-NOTHING
SON OF THE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT GETS MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FROM A BIG COMPANY
IN ONE OF THE WORLD'S MOST
CORRUPT NATIONS, UKRAINE,
YOU MUST IMPEACH HIM.
WASHINGTON MAY BE THE MOST
POWERFUL CITY IN AMERICA.
AT THE SAME TIME IT'S FULL
OF SAD PEOPLE GRASPING FOR
THINGS TO COMPLAIN ABOUT
THAT THEY HOPE MIGHT GIVE
MEANING TO THEIR DREARY
LIVES.
THIS MORNING ONE DEMOCRAT
EVEN COMPLAINED ABOUT THE
WITNESSES WHO WERE
TESTIFYING.
NOT BECAUSE THEY WERE BIASED
OR UNQUALIFIED OR
IRRELEVANT.
NOT BECAUSE THEY WERE OFF
TRACK OR HAD BAD IDEAS BUT
BECAUSE THEY WERE THE WRONG
COLOR.
>> IT HURTS MY HEART,
MR. SPEAKER, TO SEE THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HEARING
EXPERTS ON THE TOPIC OF
IMPEACHMENT AND NOT ONE
PERSON OF COLOR AMONG THE
EXPERTS.
>> Tucker: WASHINGTON THINKS